Ось це такий стан був кожен день від 24-го числа.
Ти плачеш від новин, ти плачеш від усього.
Тобі не хочеться їсти, ми втрачали вагу разом з нею. Зазвичай вагітні мають набирати вагу...
Організм вагітної жінки чутливіший до зовнішніх факторів, зокрема, до стресу.
Через війну тисячі вагітних українок пережили великі потрясіння.
І навіть ті майбутні мами, яким вдалося швидко виїхати з гарячих точок, відчули вплив стресу на себе.
Альона Гавриленко - одна з таких породіль. 24-го лютого жінка прокинулася від вибухів у Києві.
Чоловік Альони вивіз її у містечко в Житомирській області, однак спокійним перебування там родина назвати не могла.
Над нами через день пролітали винищувачі. Все це було чути. Якщо ховатися, то тільки в погріб.
Тому що це приватний будинок.
Я була на 8-му місяці, і якось не дуже зручно спускатися в погріб.
Хоча якщо хочеш жити, будеш ладен на все. Коли ситуація почала нагнітатися, ми прийняли рішення поїхати на Львів.
Альона стала на облік у пологовий будинок на Львівщині.
Жінка хвилювалася, що через стрес маля народиться передчасно чи з ускладненнями.
Зрештою Альоні пощастило - пологи відбулися у правильний термін, однак, таке буває не з усіма породіллями.
Розуміємо, що ті всі, скажімо, виїзди з гарячих точок були і складні по часу, по умовах.
Тому що пацієнти розповідали, що по поїздах їхали і по дві доби.
Без води і без умов, санітарно-епідеміологічного якогось такого середовища. І машинами це все саме.
Лише у цьому пологовому будинку у Львові від початку війни вже 200 переселенок мали пологи,
зокрема, народили 6 двієнь. Однак, за словами лікарки, особливо в перші дні війни, стрес ставав причиною багатьох передчасних пологів.
У нашій ситуації стрес сприяє, як ми бачимо, передчасним пологам. Дуже часто ці дітки народжують незрілі.
У різних термінах, край незрілості, глибока недоношеність - 23-24 тижні, де важко виходити таку дитинку.
І звичайно, є більш пізні терміни, де надати допомогу і виходити цю дитинку передчасно народжену більше є можливості, оскільки організм більше готовий.
Окрім того, переселенки переважно їдуть без базових речей для немовлят - ліжечок, візків, памперсів, повзунків.
Хоча в пологовому жінки отримують допомогу, де облаштовувати першу домівку для немовлят, вони не знають.
Галина Голець з Миколаєва народила свого сина на майже місяць раніше за очікуваний термін.
Жінка добиралася до Львова три доби. Коли дісталася пологового, була впевнена, що з її плодом все добре.
Початок 8-го місяця, я стала тут на облік. Спочатку наче все було добре, але потім уже, як пішла на УЗД,
то вже виявили проблему, що дитинка відстає у розвитку трішки за фізичними параметрами, що вага дуже маленька.
Що плацента вже зріла, і було небезпечно далі ходити вагітною.
Тепер немовля Галини виходжують в інкубаторі. Жінка вважає, що стрес був одним з чинників, чому виникла необхідність передчасних пологів.
Ну, звісно, я перехворіла двічі коронавірусом, і тут війна, звісно, воно все позначається на фоні.
Страшно мені було, звісно, я не була готова до того, та і взагалі першу дитинку народжувала сама, а то кесареве мені робили, це різні справи.
Попри те, що пологовий готовий приймати вимушених переселенок і надалі, Марія Малачинська розуміє,
що ситуація зі стресом нікуди не зникне, допоки триває війна.
Ми побачимо, як це зараз буде, оскільки війна триває, на жаль...
Ці всі хвилювання, можливо, такі гострі знялися, але постійні такі...
люди живуть все одно в стресі, і ця постійна невідомість у завтрашньому дні, навіть в тій хвилині, пов'язана з повітряними тривогами,
і з інформаційним простором, переглядають телебачення, радіо. Тому дуже все психологічно непросто.
Жінки трохи заспокоюються, коли після важкої дороги, ними починають опікуватися професіонали з пологового.
Однак абсолютного спокою молоді мами не мають навіть тут.
Весь час коли звучить ця тривога, сирена на телефоні, ти просто так здригаєшся, і пульс наче зараз вискочить просто.
Особливо після Маріуполя, взагалі небезпечно, тому що ти розумієш, що для них не проблема влучити і у Львові.
Страшно, звісно, але страх за дитину був більший...
За словами адміністрації пологового центру, поки що у них вистачає обладнання і місця
як для місцевих майбутніх мам, так і для переміщених.
Однак якщо кількість переселенок збільшиться, то інкубаторів для недоношених немовлят може забракнути.